chaque jour de la semaine amy lee moore
répète inlassablement les mêmes jeunes
avaient commencé le débat avec 300
livres j'ai des films reprendre en main
j'ai commencé le croupier est autant
qu'à vous esclaffer de la forte
actuellement sur la femme la torture est
la deuxième plus forte au canada
j'étais mort
une femme dans des concours de force
cela peut paraître curieuse et pourtant
il y à plus de 100 ans au québec une
dénommée madame h cloutier revendiquer
le titre de femme la plus forte du monde
[Musique]
mais qui pouvait bien être cette madame
h coutier dont on trouve la tombe à
watson pan et qui n'a même pas de prénom
nous nous rendons à la société
d'histoire de la haute yamaska et là une
première découverte
madame h cloutier serait en réalité
marie-louise sirois même si peu de
traces relate cette histoire elle est
née à la pocatière en 1868 et puis la
famille part pour les états unis
et puis elle en art et en récoltiez un
homme de roxton pound qui lui aussi est
venu vivre aux états unis
il détiendra aussi les têtes de champion
homme fort des états unis
les exploits de marie-louise sirois qui
entre temps avait pris comme nom de
scène celui de son mari devenant ainsi
madame henri cloutier frappe
l'imaginaire encore aujourd'hui par
exemple soulevé d'une main 510 leaf avec
son dos soulever une plateforme de 2500
lits et à la manière de louis cyr
retenir deux chevaux de 1400 lits
foutez moi on a la même grandeur donc 5
pieds 10 qui à l'époque était une femme
à la limite géant on est sensiblement le
même possible entre 190 de senlis même
aux archives nationales du québec
on trouve peu de traces de marie denis
sirois on se demande pourquoi
l'essentiel de sa vie s'est passé et de
sa vie adulte notamment et de femmes
fortes s'est passé aux états unis on
trouve quand même ceci dans la presse du
25 mai 1898 elle aurait lancé un défi à
louis cyr mais attention son biographe
officiel en doute il ya eu aucune
rencontre entre une femme si forte soit
elle et louis cyr ça c'est clair on
devait protéger cette image de l'homme
le plus fort du monde qui est louis cyr
pour des raisons politiques et pour des
raisons culturelles également c'est l
affirmation du canada français qui
revendiquait d'avoir l'homme le plus
fort du monde en ses murs
et comme nationalité de naissance même
si le duel tant attendu n'aura pas lieu
personne ne contestera alors la force
exceptionnelle de marie louise marie
louise sirois cloutier était
probablement une des cinq femmes les
plus fortes au monde
elle en fera la démonstration en
parcourant pendant une vingtaine
d'années
les états unis et le canada notamment
avec au cirque de hector décarie pour
l'époque c'était vraiment exceptionnel
fallait revoir un certain courage pour
pour se présenter dans un monde d'hommes
c'est sûr qu'il devait avoir un un
plaisir coupable avec les hameaux
tendant à l'époque qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être plus encore à l'époque où les
femmes avaient un peu moins leur place
dans ce milieu là non aujourd'hui c'est
encore nouveau mais à cette époque
c'était vraiment une femme différente
dans un milieu d'hommes les exploits de
marie-louise d'il ya cent ans sont
aujourd'hui une véritable source de
motivation pour emilie elle aurait dû
revoir lee qui valent 1 de renommée et
de notoriété de louis cyr en attendant
cette reconnaissance des milliards de
vivante la tradition des femmes fortes
du québec et rend hommage à cette
pionnière madame h cloutier kumari guy
sirois
mais qu'importe le choix du nom elle
demeure à jamais la femme la plus forte
du monde
[Musique]